greetings to all of you I'm really
excited to announce that we've reached
I've reached the $500 mark on my patreon
drawing project and so I want to thank
all the patrons that have been
contributing to this profusely I'm
really excited I am happy with the
drawings that have been happening so far
and now at the 500 mark I'm going to
ramp things up start making more
drawings at least two drawings a month
plus I'm going to start making videos
documenting some of the some of the
drawings I'm going to make and so to
kind of celebrate and to start I thought
I would make one of the drawings that
the $50 contributors have suggested at
the fifty dollar mark the people who
give 50 can ask for a particular drawing
and so I'm going to start with the first
drawing that was suggested to me by Jove
RJ's he actually asked me to make
something that I promised myself I would
never make when I started making icons
when I started carving icons I promised
myself that I would never make a
reproduction of the famous six century
encaustic icon of Christ it's one of the
most famous images in Christianity and
it is so particular so unique that I
told myself I wouldn't even try to touch
it I had seen so many people try to make
reproductions of it and fail at
capturing the essence of that image but
when Joe asked me at first I thought no
no no I'm not I'm not going to do it but
then slowly as the week's went on it was
kind of mulling over in my mind and I
thought okay this isn't a carving this I
made this patreon project to push myself
further and to try new things and so I'm
actually going to try to make this image
and I'm going to document it as I'm
going I'm a bit nervous I'm a bit
terrified to be honest but I'm going to
spend a lot of time looking at the image
and I'm not going to try to make a
reproduction like a photographic
reproduction of it
I'm going to try to capture as much as I
can of the the mysterious aspect of that
of that image one of the important
things for me in making this project was
that I tried to be as freehand as
possible I mean there are methods of
drawing using grids and whatnot
to be exact and so I wanted to avoid
those methods because the the purpose
that I was that I had in in drawing
these images was so that I can really
focus and kind of enter them into my
hand as much as it as getting a good
drawing on paper and so by drawing it
freehand I have to be way more attentive
to what I'm doing
than if I would use a more technical
process I mean I guess the the the
puzzle of this image is how to make the
image without it looking like it's two
different faces while at the same time
preserving the duality which appears in
his expression
so I finished drawing I have to say that
the difficulties that I was expecting
are the same one that I faced at first I
thought I was going to be successful but
as I was going through the drawing
especially when I reached the beard and
neck I realized that the effect that we
get from the drawing is based on a very
painterly approach it's based on an
almost impressionistic feeling of the
painting and so they help me to
understand why so many iconographer
today fail to reproduce this image
successfully because most of modern
iconography has a very linear technique
and so it struggles to to to find where
the form ends and where the forms begin
and so what happened is during the
drawing I ended up having to resort to
more painterly strategies especially
around the neck and the beard and so
leaving certain parts purposefully vague
and gray were the only way I was able to
even come close to to suggesting with on
the image and so I have to say it
convinced me even more and making a
drawing of this that that I should never
attempt to carve it because to reach the
kind of vague impressionistic feeling in
a carving is not possible and so yeah so
it was a good experiment and I'm not
completely happy with it but I think I
did the best I could and so I'll leave
all of you to judge whether it's been in
any way successful so thank you and I'll
see you in my next video